one of the key elements in lifting a
dish from the ordinary to extraordinary
is texture get the texture right and you
take food to that next level of
indulgence
[Music]
my aim when i'm cooking at home during
the christmas holidays is to make dishes
with the minimum fuss
that still deliver the wow factor my
next recipe for panna cotta
takes all the right boxes it's easy to
make and has a silky smooth texture
that makes it one of the world's sexiest
desserts
first add 250 milliliters of cream to a
pan
then pour in 50 mils of milk and add 50
grams of caster sugar
get the sugar in early because it stops
the milk and cream from boiling over
give that a little stir bring that out
to the bowl
panna cotta which means cooked cream in
italian can be flavoured with anything
from vanilla to coffee to chocolate
i'm giving mine a grown-up kick with a
splash of rum in
once the cream has come to the boil take
it off the heat and add a couple of
leaves of gelatin that have been soaked
in cold water
and squeezed dry then whisk them in
the gelatine sets the cook cream
so we want that really nice sort of
blemonge
texture rich silky
and incredibly smooth once the gelatine
has dissolved
pour the panna cotta straight into
serving glasses traditionally
it's set in moulds then turned out onto
a plate but i'm keeping mine simple
leave a little space on top for the
glaze
now set them into the fridge
[Music]
beautiful next the pomegranate glaze
add some caster sugar to the pan and
pour in pomegranate juice
then simply bring it to the boil and
reduce it down to the consistency
of a sticky syrup
[Music]
in iran where pomegranates originated
they used this sweet sticky syrup to
flavour chicken and game birds
a beautiful rich sticky glaze
pour that into a jar leave that to cool
down
take the panna cotta from the fridge
they set beautifully
and they're not too firm just
slightly bouncy a little bit springy on
top
carefully pour the cooled pomegranate
glaze over
just roll them around a little bit just
to fill those edges
finally take a bar of chocolate that's
been chilled in the freezer so it's
easier to use
and scrape off thin shards almost like
sort of
chocolate gold leaf and sprinkle it on
top
[Music]
when your friends or neighbours pop
round for tea at christmas it's great if
your biscuit tin is well stocked
having a homemade shortbread on hand is
an ideal way to revitalize spanish
guests
it's delicious on its own or can be
quickly dressed up if they demand
something fancier
first slice open the vanilla pod and
scrape out the seeds
now the flavor in those seeds
is mind-blowing look at it beautiful
now two whole eggs in
two give that a whisk
[Music]
next add 125 grams of unsalted butter to
the mixer
once the butter's soft add 90 grams of
caster sugar
and cream them together until they're
lovely and smooth
gradually pour in the beaten eggs and
vanilla seeds
add a pinch of salt and beat thoroughly
until the mixture becomes paler
[Music]
then put in 250 grams of plain flour and
mix until it forms a dough
should just be nice and firm
slightly soft and not too wet
perfect be careful because you're
holding your hands for too long
it starts to melt flour your hands on
the board
and shape the dough into a circle it's
got a really nice soft
sensual sexy feel really nice
and creamy now roll it out to the
thickness of one centimeter
cut out a large circle then put it onto
a baking tray lined with parchment and
decorate
[Music]
half again
just like my grandma's tonight thumb in
and in chill the shortbread for an hour
to help it set
then bake it in a medium oven for 20
minutes until it turns a pale golden
color
just sprinkle a little bit of sugar
really nice to do when it's just come
out so it's sort of
it melts into the shortbread nice and
generous
and that's perfect for a cup of tea
mid-afternoon as well as filling your
biscuit tin over christmas
this shortbread can easily be
transformed into a great festive dessert
[Music]
using a hot spoon scoop out lozenges of
creme fraiche
and sit on top then grate over the zest
of a clementine
and finish with clementine halves the
tartness
of the creme fresh works with the
sweetness
of the clementine
another thing i always do the day before
christmas is knock up a batch of mint
chocolate truffles
their child's plate to make and have a
wonderful fresh mint flavor
the perfect after dinner chocolates
right
megan jack i need some help yeah
chocolate mint truffles first things
first yeah
what we should do is get this block of
dark chocolate and just break it up into
small pieces
okay make this for you jack that's for
you mate where did you get that time
from
not a tie but very smart
right mint chocolate truffles
the cigarette here is getting that
mint flavor into the chocolate
so look best thing to do get a little
bunch of mint
and just lightly bruise it you can
flavour the truffles with whatever takes
your fancy
from fresh chili which gives it a
surprisingly delicious kick
to orange zest to a splash of brandy
right double cream
and single cream in
[Music]
the cream makes the truffles wonderfully
soft luscious and rich
next add a generous pour of honey which
helps to sweeten the dark chocolate
now bring that out to the boil now the
secret is we pour that
on top of the chocolate okay so we
literally got two minutes to get this
done
quick that's why i need some help in
half
dad yes can you beat this
up with a rolling pin it's a very good
idea oh would it be too small
no it's a very good idea because what we
can't afford to do is for the cream to
reduce if the cream reduces
then the consistency of the truffle
becomes too hard but it's a very good
idea jack you know that
now gently with that
i've got your boyfriend a present yeah
just ask it all right just ask him
what's he buying there them
what your big sister's got more than one
boyfriend
i haven't got one giant slop oh go
got my girlfriend jack what's her name
emma what you bought emma for christmas
don't tell seriously dad yeah a tablet
too daddy's restaurant
next add 130 grams of softened butter to
give the troubles a glorious richness
and sheen
break up into small little bits yeah
nice good once the cream of milk have
come to the boil yeah
really nice i can really smell the mint
strain over the broken chocolate
that smells delicious push that mint
flavor through there
so it really does come out yeah so it
really does come out
give that a nice stir oh look i can see
the chocolate at the bottom
see how the chocolate is dissolving and
that honey
has given it a really nice glaze
sweetness as well because it's bitter
chocolate that's right dark chocolate
and then the butter starts to give the
chocolate a really nice shine
so then what will actually happen it
happened
that look at that beautiful
right that will let the spoon put your
tongue out
right then pour the chocolate into a
container and chill in the fridge for
about an hour to firm up
jack i don't want any fingers in there
you can see let it go nice and firm
as the truffle mixture sets prepare the
coating so have one
for the adults and cocoa powder yeah and
one
with flakes you know there's a surprise
surprise so wait put your hands down
put your hands down so look you just go
like that and twist the flake
onto the plate you can coat the truffles
on anything you like
finely chopped pistachios or almonds
work really well with the mint
or to give them a bit of crunch plain
brown sugar
[Music]
once the truffle mixture is set it's
time to roll out the chocolates
mega two oh dear right okay i'm gonna
show you one first yeah so hands
really nice and cold now the secret is
in there
wow that's really going hard manipulate
it first like that
and then look roll and then quickly bang
look nothing on my hands shake off
excess
and then just on beautiful
now in there
and let's go come on jack
dear hello when you're ready
we've been using by the time we get one
done
[Music]
try and drop it on there rather than
place it on there mate okay
the nice thing about making them by hand
they're not all the exact same size yeah
handmade chocolate mint truffles jack
the secret is a truffle
it's a one bite wonder not a golf ball
how'd you hurry up because the ganache
starts melting
we're in trouble i thought you said
there wasn't going to be any chocolate
on your hat
that's because you're slow show me your
hands
all right let me help you here yeah
not so big around like that like that
yep
and then like that in straight in
daddy
[Music]
try and put yours in cocoa bear this
time look put it in closer
[Music]
hi jack what i've said quick um and
whilst he's gone let's turn these into
proper little truffle shells cut them
down
when the truffles are coated and the
kids are cleaned up decorate them with
sprigs of mint
so look slicing chris yes christmas here
that's right
would you like to try one oh yes please
okay which one should we go for fake or
coco
flake
[Music]
really taste the mint you can really
taste them in candy
then price the travels away from the
kids and pop in the fridge ready for
christmas day
another job done
[Music]
every year when i was growing up my mum
made a traditional christmas pudding
now i'm getting her back in the kitchen
to help me cook my updated version
a modern light steam pudding with whisky
cream
it's super simple to make and
deliciously delicate to eat
and it can be flombated at the table so
you don't miss out on all that drama
all right mum welcome to a proper
kitchen now
today we're not going to burn anything
we're going to make a really nice
fragrance
steamed yeah sponge pudding why are you
looking for christmas
yeah sponge well i mean we never get to
eat christmas pudding because always a
little bit too full so i want to make
something a little bit lighter people
like to stick to tradition and christmas
coming
would you mind if i just try something a
little bit different
first mum grates the zest of an orange
into a lightly buttered pudding basin
whilst i get on with a sponge mix add
210 grams of butter
and 210 grams of light brown sugar to
the mixer and beets
do you think your weight is good trust
me
mum i know it's my kitchen but there's
only one way and that is my way that
would be cheeky now
is that enough chef um did you use all
the orange i don't like waste
so sorry
then pour a few tablespoons of maple
syrup into the pudding basin
and put in three bay leaves bay leaves
are an extraordinary versatile herb
their bittersweet spicy taste works
brilliantly in everything from meat
stews
marinades and fish dishes to sweet
custards and rice puddings
to finish the sponge mix beat together
four eggs and slowly add to the cream
butter and sugar
[Music]
and again please nice and slow slowly
there you go all right now
the flour and baking powder sieve in 100
grams of self-raising flour
and three teaspoons of baking powder
then add a teaspoon of ground cloves
it gives that really nice sort of and a
cd
richness to it there you are okay thank
you
you look at the measuring so you get
that nice
right a little pinch of salt and i'm
just going to give that a nice little
mix
fold that flower in why don't you use
the risk when you're doing that because
i want to knock all that air out there
now
into the bowl okay
steaming the pudding in a sealed
container means it cooks slowly
and keeps in all the moisture making the
sponge lovely and light
lovely
[Music]
to cover the pudding with a circle of
baking parchment take a square sheet
unfold
[Music]
butter one side so it doesn't stick when
the pudding cooks
[Music]
and tie it tightly over the basin can
you put your thing on there for yourself
lovely temple
shiny side out and twist
at the end once the pudding's sealed
place a ramekin in the pan
this keeps the basin off the bottom so
it can steam evenly
saucer in the bottom of it a little
sausage ready pour in hot water
pop in the pudding and steam for one and
a half hours topping it with hot water
if it balls dry
[Music]
[Applause]
to go with the steam pudding we're
making a super simple whiskey cream
start by whisking 150 milliliters of
double cream
and and whisk lovely i always get the
hard jobs gordy
i'll just think of those bingo wings mom
that's all i mean bingo hands
smack in a minute eyes down
yes there you are all right thank you
now a little splash of whiskey
a little drop yeah just a little drop
okay
lovely and then finally a little bit
irish cream
now you're talking now we're talking
excellent or it smells delicious doesn't
it we'll stop there mum just in case we
have butter in 30 seconds time thank you
that's a nightmare in the kitchen okay
that was lovely put the whiskey cream in
the fridge
until you're ready to serve now
that should be ready i'm hoping of
course when the pudding has finished
steaming
turn it out onto a plate does the trick
wow look at that no no
doesn't it just loosen it a little bit
on the sides
thank you now
nice fingers crossed this pudding is
another dish you can make in advance
simply reheat by steaming again
oops daisy glad you're happy
yeah do you mind
you go gorgeous you're sure
[Music]
there we are nice nice nice nice
it's lovely isn't it that
smells amazing to follow the pudding eat
some whiskey lie to the table
and pour over
you